[Music]
this is Rob zero six - now I'm back from
school now so I have some time to make
some videos and I'm ready to go if you
got something you want to see let me
know just leave me a comment below or
two or three whatever you please I know
I can rap so don't hate on me all right
so I'm having a little bit of fun with
my keyboard but I think you get the
point I'm home for the summer and I
definitely want to get some new videos
out real soon one of the videos I want
to upload is a project that I've been
working on for the last month or so in
restorative dentistry - so I'm going to
have a link hopefully over here
somewhere where you can click on that
and that'll take you to that it's pretty
interesting so if you're interested in
possibly going into dentistry that would
be a cool thing to check out another
thing that I definitely want to get out
I know that I've had a bunch of requests
for the origami ring it is pretty simple
to make so I figured I would go over how
to do that so as you can see that's the
gist you just need a simple dollar bill
and another thing that I definitely want
to teach would be possibly the origami
rose
so my chair is breaking but that looks
something like this and you know I'll
show you how to make the stem and
everything so if you're interested in
making that then I'm probably going to
be teaching this sometime too soon also
I did have a question if I was going to
make the Rose tutorial it would probably
be over 20 minutes long so would you
guys rather have a 20-word possibly even
30 minute video or what did you rather
me split it into two parts so just leave
me a comment below let me know one other
things that it's my birthday today so
I'm actually 25 years old and I know
quarter-century so I'm probably going
you upload that project video a little
bit later and I'm going to be
celebrating my birthday today okay so
I'll definitely get some videos out real
soon but thank you guys so much for
understanding and being patient the
shoe-tying tutorial I definitely want to
get out sometime soon also um but let me
know leave me a comment below and yeah
I will definitely see you guys soon in a
video